hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wellig
koch etwas indisches und es gibt ein
indisches lammkarree und ich sehe schon
mal ganz gerne morath auch ich mag
einfach die kombination von
verschiedenen gewürzen ich finde dass
schmidt dann immer ganz außergewöhnlich
für dieses land curry brauche ich später
eine gewürzmischung der indische das
heißt die heißt masala und die kammer
entweder fertig kaufen oder mir bereitet
sie einfach selber zu ich werde zuerst
einmal die gefühlsmischung zubereiten
und zeigt euch dann später noch die
zutaten für slum curry für die
gewürzmischung brauche ich einen
esslöffel kreuzkümmel eineinhalb
teelöffel koriander eineinhalb teelöffel
kardamon eineinhalb tele ffh einen
teelöffel zimt und einen teelöffel
kurkuma einen halben teelöffel nelken
brauchen einen halben teelöffel muskat
und später noch ein paar lorbeerblätter
ich nehme jetzt erstmal die gewürze ich
könnte jetzt entweder mit einem mörser
zerkleinern habe ich aber leider nicht
ich nehme dafür die gewürzmühle und
vermische jetzt alle zutaten hier zu
reden
die karton kapseln habe ich jetzt
übrigens gelöst als ich nehme nur die
das innere mit hier rein dann noch die
muskatnuss die reibe ich jetzt aber
schon mal hier rein und die
lorbeerblätter die gebe ich dann später
im ganzen meter zu oft gewürzt mit unser
kleiner
die gewürzmischung ist jetzt fertig und
stieß stelle ich jetzt zu den restlichen
zutaten
ich brauche für dieses rezept 200 gramm
kichererbsen die habe ich bereits
gestern abend in 600 milliliter wasser
eingelegt 500 gramm lammschulter
einstiegen war das in etwa zwei bis drei
zentimeter 3 esslöffel butter schmalz
oder g 150 milliliter kokosmilch etwas
salz und pfeffer cayennepfeffer für die
schärfe eine zwiebel hier habe ich noch
meine gewürzmischung eine halbe
zimtstange und die zwei lorbeerblätter
drei tomaten und zwar ist der für
getrocknete minze ich nehme jetzt zuerst
das fleisch und schneit es in zwei
zentimeter große würfel
jetzt gebe ich die drei esslöffel butter
schmalz in einen topf voller hitze sind
jetzt brauche ich das fleisch in
mehreren fraktionen an und nimmt dann
auch wieder raus
in der zwischenzeit kann ich jetzt schon
mal die kichererbsen abgießen
aber die flüssigkeit die eine weiße
flüssigkeit sollte auf jeden fall
auffallen und kann jetzt auch schon mal
die zwiebel in feine streifen schneiden
denn irgendwas schädigt und zwar nehme
ich dann meist einen löffel dafür und
ziehe einfach so ein bisschen die haut
ab aber immer nur an den stellen an
denen die haut auch so hart ist und
sonst was ich die schale immer ganz gern
und dann wird er irgendwie auch ganz
fein gewürfelt
jetzt ist es fleisch angebraten ich
hab's auch rausgenommen und jetzt frage
ich im restlichen fed noch die zwiebel
und die inga würfel an
jetzt gebe ich noch die zimtstange und
die zwei blätter mit dass sie kurz mit
an
da versteckt sich das aroma noch ein
bisschen und vom einweichwasser habe ich
jetzt hier bereits 250 milliliter
abgemessen
jetzt kommen einfach alle zutaten wieder
zurück also fleisch
die treffen
das einweichwasser die kokosmilch muss
das ganze ganz kurz aufkochen und dann
schaltet den herd auf etwa 340 stufe und
dann muss dieses lammkarree etwa 45 bis
50 minuten schmoren
das lamm paris oder nicht dauerhaft
kochen sondern nur leicht zimmern und
falls ihr noch flüssigkeit benötigt kann
man auch noch das restliche ein
weißwasser benutzen
und ich habe das jetzt genommen damit
einfach so ein bisschen wenig wert und
daneben auch gefunden wird und gewürze
gebe ich dann erst später mit dazu das
lammkarree durfte jetzt kochen und ich
habe bereits nach 25 minuten etwa die
zimtstange entfernt damit der geschmack
einfach nicht zu intensiv wird die
killer apps sind sie zu dem zeitpunkt
schon weichen des fleisches auch schon
weich
das heißt ich kann es jetzt auch direkt
würzen dafür gebe ich jetzt sei es mit
rein
dann kommt noch etwas cayennepfeffer mit
rein als ich mag gern etwas schärfer wer
es nicht gerne so scharf markt gibt
einfach nur ein bisschen was rein oder
gar kein treffer und dann kommt noch ein
teelöffel etwa von unserer
gewürzmischung mit drauf und da kam er
dann auch immer wieder abschminken
was jetzt noch fehlt sind die tomaten
die stele ich jetzt einmal wenn jetzt
nicht so ein sparschäler habt der die
tomaten schale entfernt also da die
tomaten haut entfernen kann
dann müsste die jetzt erst mit heißem
wasser übergießen und dann einfach die
haut abziehen es geht
die tomaten werden jetzt in würfel
geschnitten
dafür bin ich vorne immer erst den strom
die kommen dann direkt mit dazu und wenn
ihr jetzt merkt ihr habt zu wenig
flüssigkeit gibt die entweder noch ein
weißwasser mit dazu oder einfach nur ein
bisschen kokosmilch je nachdem wie sehr
ihr den kokons geschmack merkt wenn ihr
die flüssigkeit hier gerne noch etwas
gebunden möchte dazu gebunden haben
möchte gibt's noch ein bisschen
tomatenmark mit rein als ich bei mir
kommt es unserem teelöffel tomatenmark
steht dazu und sobald ich das ganze
abgeschmeckt habe ist das gericht auch
schon jetzt ist das lammkarree fertig
uns de moura darf direkt probieren ja
ich freue mich richtig ich mag das brot
zu extrem
bei mir gibt's nämlich brot dazu nahm
brand nicht sagen anders alles um ranjid
brot und ich finde es ist jedoch zu
ähnlich ja war einst geht's um das
karree barcelona für sein buch liebe ihn
geschichte ich also waren sie immer auf
jeden fall seine kita apps und möglichst
genau auf den funk gekochtes sind weder
zu weich noch zu hart und islam ist
wirklich sehr zart und ich finde hatte
gewürze darin richtig genial
also wir kochen ja wirklich jeden tag
aber so indisches schon außergewöhnlich
mit den verschiedenen gewürzen
ach gott was ich vergessen hat die
winzer zu lesen da muss man mental drauf
die minze macht das ganze nicht
geschmeckt geschmeckt noch besser als
als man ihn ja also es ist richtig ich
auch mit liebe gekocht wurden finde es
toll an politischen essen ist immer was
ganz ganz anders schmeckt sie ganz
anders sind und meine absolute
abwechslung finde ich auch total
wahnsinnig zu bauen
winter vergessen also die minze einfach
kurz vor dem servieren noch mit drauf
streuen
tutmann gefallen macht windes macht dann
macht es brot dazu und auskömmlich auf
was auch gut passen würde wäre aber auch
ein reich aber ich glaube wirklich ein
fan dieses bootes wirklich brot reis und
biss dem
was mir persönlich noch dazu ganz gut
schmecken würde wer spielt wo auf spiele
eingekauft wie es einfach im blut
ja also falls ihr dieses rezept nach
machen wollt dann geht auf meinem blog
celis - blog.de demokrat scheint
wirklich sehr gut zu schmecken
wir werden das es gleich zusammen mit
unseren gästen auf essen und viel spaß
danach machen einen guten appetit und
bis zum nächsten mal warten bis alle da
so wirklich gehört aber mein facebook
foto das mit macht